what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it's been a pretty rough road for
blad so far in the MCU going through
several different rewrites different
writers and talks about the movie quite
possibly being cancelled Mersa Ali may
be walking out of it fortunately for us
that did not happen and blade is still a
go with Mersa Ali although it's had a
lot of rough patches it looks like
things are a go with blade now and it
looks like they might have locked down a
final script and last night Insider
Daniel rpk released some details about
the upcoming blade film along with some
other projects which we'll talk about as
well in this video one of those being
The Punisher but let's dive into some of
the details for the blade movie because
it does seem like they have kept some
things from the previous script and
there is a little bit of a tie-in to Kit
Harrington's danne Whitman from the
eternals so if you love Marvel and want
to stay up to date on the MCU be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos we're also giving away a
PS5 and Xbox series X more on the
giveaway at the end of the video so
according to Insider Daniel rpk blade is
still going to be first and foremost I
know a lot of people are wondering about
this rated R it seems like Marvel
Studios really doesn't have a problem
anymore going into rated R I mean
Deadpool 3 is obviously going to be
rated R and will probably be pretty
runchy and violent much like the other
two Deadpool films and this is coming
from Marvel Studios and Disney so they
clearly have no problem doing rated R
films even in the MCU and I think it's
actually a very good thing because some
projects like Deadpool 3 like blade need
to be rated R there are some very
serious characters in the comics who
cuss a lot who are very violent and they
need to depict those accurately on
screen so it's good to know that the
mouse isn't really trying to water
anything down so blade is still going to
be rated R and according to Daniel rpk
it's still going to be a period piece
meaning it is going to take play
sometime probably pretty far in the past
and I'm okay with this because in the
comics blade was born in the early 1900s
Eric Brooks AKA blade was born on
October 24th 1929 so it would make sense
that this would be a period piece now I
want to say hopefully they are staying
true to a lot of what happened in the
comics however in the comics he gets
bitten by morbius and I'm not sure
really how they're going to include that
in the MCU yes Sony is playing nice with
Marvel Studios and vice versa but I'm
not sure we're going to ever really see
morbius in the MCU unless it's for a
pretty good meme in secret Wars and the
reason I bring up morbius is because it
sounds like he somewhat has to do with
the plot that Marvel Studios is planning
not saying they're going to include him
but in the comics he is included Daniel
rpk goes on to say that Lilith is going
after blad's daughter's blood to create
an army of day Walkers her weapon is the
Ebony Blade now there's a lot to say
about the ebony blade and the connection
to danne Whitman from the eternals but
first let's talk about the day walkers
in Lilith now there are two sides to
Lilith in Marvel Comics and the MCU is
most likely going to adapt both based
off of what we know so far one is that
Lilith is the first ever child The First
Daughter of Dracula before he was even a
vampire Dracula was forced by his father
to marry Lilith's mother zofia however
once his father died he renounced Sophia
and he forced her and his daughter
Lilith to leave the castle so that he
could marry the person that he truly
loved Maria now unfortunately Sophia
would end up killing herself and Lilith
was raised by gypsies particularly an
elder Gypsy named Gretchen unfortunately
once Dracula became a vampire he went
and he attacked the Gypsies and he
killed Gretchen's son so enraged she put
a curse on Lilith turning her into a
vampire that would make her hunt Dracula
and that was actually a part of the
curse that she had to hunt and oppose
her father Dracula but Lilith had very
different powers from a normal vampire
she could walk out in daylight without
being burnt or killed she did not fear
holy symbols and didn't need to sleep
inside of a coffin with her native soil
in it she was what is called a day
Walker and at one point in time in the
comics blade was a day Walker as well
when he got bit by morbius a vampire who
can go out in the daytime can walk
around in the sunlight and not be killed
hence daywalker but there is another
side to to Lilith she is actually the
mother of all demons the demon Lilith is
an ancient demon goddess and sorceress
and she is actually rumored to be one of
the main villains of the supernatural
side of the MCU rumored to interact with
Mesto and the supernatural side as well
but that's a story for another day in
the comics she gives birth to demons and
they are called lyen and they all have
lives of their own but they always
remain obedient to their mother Lilith
so this might be what what is going to
happen in Blade Lilith might be having
children and wants to turn them into day
Walkers so she could take over the world
or at least kill blade for whatever
reason for whatever story they decide to
go with in the MCU again I don't think
morbius is going to be in the film and
Dracula is half vampire half human which
is why he can walk around in sunlight
but some way day Walkers are going to be
involved according to Daniel rpk so
assuming morbius doesn't pop up in the
MCU they're going to have to go with
another character or another story of
how these day Walkers are born now he
says Lilith is going to have the Ebony
Blade and that sounds awesome we did see
Dane Whitman get the ebony blade in the
eternals post credit scene but keep in
mind that is present time like 2022
blade is going to take place in the
early 1900s so this is actually before
danne Whitman even gets the blade but we
know that whatever happens in Blade it's
going to end up in the hands of danne
Whitman now for those of you who might
not be familiar with what the ebony
blade is it's really cool but it also
kind of sucks it's an incredibly
powerful blade that is actually the
counterpart to Excalibur the dark
counterpart and according to the god
null who created the Symbiotes the ebony
blade is a symbiotic Divine weapon with
the potential to destroy worlds and its
true power is beyond the ability of
Mortals to comprehend or unleash it's
said that the Ebony Blade was forged by
Merlin and Sir Percy from the starstone
meteorite the Ebony Blade was enchanted
to cut through any object to prevent the
death of its wielder and to deflect any
magic but it carries a curse that slowly
corrupts any user and causes a lust for
violence Bloodshed and death it
basically causes the wielder to turn
into what they refer to as a
bloodthirsty Berserker and it can
actually resurrect as well it's
resurrected Dane Whitman plenty of times
in the comics and knowing this it kind
of gives you some context to the
post-credit scene for the eternals where
we see danne Whitman super super anxious
of even opening the case to look at the
blade and that's because this blade has
been in his family for Generations upon
Generations in fact sir Percy was one of
his distant ancestors what's interesting
about the blade according to null is
that the blade can only be wielded by
the impure of heart drawing out their
negative emotions so it's an extremely
powerful blade that can do a lot but it
comes at a very high price however
Lilith being a demon and a vampire
probably doesn't care too much about
that she probably just wants the blade
for all of its abilities so she'll use
the Ebony Blade to fight blade and
honestly this sounds like it could be
potentially a pretty awesome movie A lot
of people are really excited about this
and it sounds like Marvel Studios has
locked in the script Mersa Ali is still
blade and apparently likes the script as
well so things are a go for blade and
this story so far sounds pretty cool but
let me know what you think about it in
the comments down below please don't
forget to give this video a like And
subscribe to the channel to stay up to
date on the MCU and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items and some DC items the
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
one winner at the end of each month you
can find us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof